we are living through the biggest threat
this conscious faced for a generation
coronavirus has taken so much from us
it's brought normal life to a halt we
can no longer see our friends no longer
spend time with extended family and over
30,000 people have lost their lives
behind these statistics a families torn
apart by grief millions are worried
about their loved ones their jobs their
communities their families and their
future that's why when I was elected
leader of the Labour Party just over a
month ago I promised a new type of
opposition labour will always put the
national interest first we will have the
courage to support the government when
that's the right thing to do and the
courage to challenge the government
where it's getting it wrong today I
repeat that message labour has supported
locked out and we continue to do so
public health and saving lives must
always come first
whether we voted for this government or
not at this moment of national crisis we
all rely on the government to get this
right that's why we've called for a
national consensus and offer to work
with the government to defeat this
dreadful virus what we needed from the
Prime Minister last night was clarity
and reassurance we needed to hear that
nobody would be asked to go to work or
send their children to school without it
being safe to do so we needed to know
that the huge problems we've seen with
protective equipment are over that the
crisis in our care homes has finally
been gripped that everybody who needs a
test can finally get one above all we
need to know when we can see our loved
ones again prime minister said he was
setting out a road map but if we're to
complete the journey safely
a road map needs clear directions so
many of us have questions that need
answering how can we be sure our
workplaces are now safe to return to how
can we get to work safely if we need
public transport to do so
how can millions of people go back to
work while balancing childcare and
caring responsibilities how do i police
enforce these rules and why are some
parts the United Kingdom now on a
different path to others for as long as
this crisis persists
I'll keep demanding answers to these
questions because that's how we get
better decisions and better outcomes I
remain committed to working
constructively with the government in
the national interest and when this is
over and one day it will be undetermined
we will build a better society because
after all this all the sacrifice and the
loss we can't go back to business as
usual we can't go back to a society
where we clap out care as once a week
but where half of our care workers are
paid less than the real living wage we
can't go back to a society where we pay
tribute to the heroes of the Second
World War but see our care homes as an
afterthought and we can't go back to
country where we don't invest in our
public services but expect our frontline
workers to protect us when we get
through this it'll be because of the
hard work and the bravery of every key
worker as they took on this virus and
kept our country going in their courage
and their sacrifice and their bravery we
can see a better future this crisis has
brought out the resilience and the human
spirit
in all of us we must go forward with a
vision of a better society built on that
resilience and built on that human
spirit